in the long and glorious history of men
butchering each other we River folk make
the best meat how else can you explain
why anyone would stay in a land of
constant college for thousands of years
if it wasn't the first men killing the
children of the forest here
it was the animals killing the first men
and then each other even when the river
lands finally you noted behind the kings
of house justman the unusual silence of
peace attracted the storm roared
Westerman and those bloody are born to
try and take our grain gold and women
the problem is and has always been that
the Riverlands have no natural defenses
unlike the north we don't have the neck
to keep invaders waist-deep in muck
unlike the veil we don't have mountains
with narrow passes easily defended by
stable boys with slings unlike dawn we
don't have a blazing salmon well the
Dornish my ancestors may have had a
funny taste in sigils but they knew one
thing if you plan on staying in the
Riverlands you'd better have a strong
castle my ancestor axel Tully bright man
that he was realized that most soldiers
can't swim and raised his castle of
Riverrun or the red fork and the
tumblestone rivers meet
he built the right up to the water on
each side daring attackers to force
across him if they wore armor they'd
drown if they didn't our archers would
feather them from the battlements as
they paddled
an army could still assault Riverrun
from the west however so my ancestors
dug a wide moat along our Stonewall
connecting the rivers either side of the
castle when any would-be conquerors
showed up
we opened a series of gates and flooded
the moat transforming river run into an
island fortress with enough stores to
last years as the invaders starved in
their camps they'd watch us fish off our
walls just for variety and because we
were bored eventually they all sculpt
home in the thousand years that River
Runner stood not once has it been taken
by force it's a proper castle you want
to you have to marry into it even the
damned phrase knew that much up jump
toll collectors living on a bridges set
of beneath about the rest of their kind
but finally a lord of a crossing passed
off one of his brew to his liege lord
house Tully
my nephew ed more people say Lord Walder
arranged the red wedding to punish Robb
Stark I say he did it just as much to
steal Riverrun
they've always envied our castle maybe
they think two rivers can wash off the
filth that coats them they'll never know
the Lannisters could grant River unto
the phrase for a thousand years but that
doesn't mean they can have it do you
think it was hard to convince Tully
soldiers to turn against the phrase do
you think we won't enjoy watching them
simple as winter bears down on that
pitiful camp I even carved a new fishing
rod for the occasion when the starving
phrase look up at our walls will wave
our traps at them